and
this guy has been inciting violence
against me he's actually gotten my
he's actually tried to get veterans to
come and kill me and my family
um who is this guy that's his name is
rick his name is rick reinerson
and he's got this blog called um uh
pick your battles and uh
he says on his blog pick your battles is
a phrase that people who
people people say when they don't battle
but sun tzu
in the art of war specifically says pick
your battles because you only have a
limited amount of energy
and where and if you can pick your
battles you will be more efficient in
how you use that energy
so what is what is his goal in battling
you or or
trying to go against you or so what is
he trying to do he's trying to silence
you what
he's he's trying he's trying to um
so his wife is a a lawyer who works for
raytheon
and has worked for johnson and johnson
in monsanto
so raytheon is the the company that has
the main
military contract for the drone
operations
so he is uh probably being directly paid
by someone to put all this stuff out
there
and he's i he's this guy is kind of
[ __ ] up because he says that he denied
when he was in the drones he denied in
order to shoot
but i'm not if he did that then he did
the right thing but
this guy was in the drone program yeah
he claims to be okay
okay and then uh he drove an
armored vehicle through border patrol
coming from new mexico and recorded it
and said and sued the border patrol for
uh
um illegal search and seizure under the
united states constitution violating his
constitutional amendment rights and
tried to make himself out to be a
whistleblower and then
when i he contacted me
and tried to get me to be part of this
group called veterans against police
abuse
and then tried to set me up with a guide
who got a like he sent me down to this
um never me he's a drunk
and everything that i've heard about him
from people in the program
uh hate him they say that he's he's
one of the worst [ __ ] people that
they've ever met
but uh he got me sent me down to this
conference
for police abuse and wanted me to hang
out with these guys
and bought my ticket um
to go there and then leave the next day
he wanted me to stay there a couple days
and i was like i don't want to do this
like i don't feel comfortable
and then got mad at me for not staying
there well the people that he wanted me
to
to hang out with and event ended up
being arrested in downtown austin that
night
um and then one day he the one day he
posted this uh thing on facebook how he
doesn't believe in free will
and he believes that we are all destined
to behave and act a certain way and i
i disagreed with him i was like i
believe in free will and i believe that
i have the choice to do what i want to
do and after i
after that he just started attacking and
everything that i did
so so this guy is just a narcissist
um with deep connect with connections to
deep pockets
and um uh has been
really trying there's a blog called this
ain't hell which is a
blog about angry veterans who just
hate people um and
uh they um they reported on me as
uh being uh they say like our contacts
inside the drone program say that
brandon bryant's a liar
and filthy piece of [ __ ] and all this
type of stuff and
um some of my grandpa's former wrestlers
are rangers and one of them came to me
and was like
you better shut up and stop telling lies
and i was like i'm not telling a lie and
he's like swear on your grandpa's life
and i was like i swear in my grandpa's
life i'm not telling you why
and this guy went back to
this group of people and they murdered
him
for standing up for me
a ranger yeah so uh this group of angry
veterans who were
who were threatening me and threatening
to kill me if i didn't shut up
this guy who was one of my grandpa's
former wrestlers came to me and was like
if you don't shut up
we're gonna hurt you we're gonna come
after you what happened to these people
that murdered him
are they injured in prison now what no
no he died and
he died in a fire house fire
and there was no sort of investigation
to homicide
nope native american kid so they didn't
they didn't do any investigation
and where was this uh here in montana
name the kid's name was jc whitaker
and uh he with a comb
yep whitaker uh and he was murdered he
was murdered
like um i also had a friend who was part
of lolsek is in a similar story
how do you know for sure he was murdered
though how do you know these people
actually
you're saying they burned his house down
within it
how do you know that though because
these guys these guys were inciting
violence against me on their website and
blog and this guy was
jc told me all the things that they were
going to do to me they were going to
kill me they were going to
torture me and murder me they're going
to kill my family as well
and he stood up for me and less than a
week after that he was killed
like these are the types of these you
know people
discredit disgruntled veterans but when
veterans feel like they've been
wronged or when they have a target like
they think i'm a traitor they
people call me a traitor or a monster i
have no friends
um and so this guy was sticking up for
me
and they killed him and then after that
happened
there was no more talk about me on their
blog until rick ryneerson
wrote a guest piece for them and started
inciting violence against me again
and another guy who's from lolsek
who um i don't know if you know who
lolsek is but it was a
a group who broke off from 4chan a
hacker group
this guy i knew personally and he was my
friend and he was actually my contact to
give me a bunch of information about
what was going on he was the one that
was following forums he was the one that
was
uh when uh the fbi came to my house
and told me that if i didn't shut up and
stop speaking then isis would come and
kill me and my mother
uh he did the research for me and found
out that it wasn't
anyone outside of the country that was
doing it was christian patriots who were
saying that i was a traitor and i
deserved to die
and i had him start researching
information about
this and he died a month later under
mysterious circumstances
so um you know there's a there's very
evil people
really evil people in this world
um back in october i had a man
throw a knife at me through my open
window
driving down a vehicle driving down the
interstate
or the the freeway um at 70 miles an
hour and i've never seen anyone throw a
knife like that except for a marine
and it hit me in the head um
and the only reason that it didn't kill
me was because it tumbled and the hilt
hit me right here in the head
and i moved my head so it would have hit
me straight in the temple but i moved my
head
slightly because i saw it coming at me
and it hit me right here in the back of
the head
um so like there are there are people
that are
actively trying to kill me in my life
and trying to hurt me and my family
because of the things that i've done
including members of my own community
and even the police department
i